The sun smooth and round and peaceful,
except when it's suddenly vomits,
radiation and plasma in random directions.
These solar flares and carnal message actions or CMS can hit earth
and have serious consequences for humanity. How exactly do they work?
How bad could they be? And can we prepare for them?
[Inaudible].
While the sun seems pretty solid, it's actually like a very hot ocean.
So hard that it rips atoms into electrons and nuclei,
all flowing around each other in a plasma.
This plasma is pushed around and shaped by the sun's magnetic field,
similar to how the sun's gravitational field reaches out to the planets and
shapes their orbits. But magnetism is very different from gravity.
Magnetism is one part of a dual force.
Electromagnetism electricity creates magnetic fields and
magnetic fields create electricity on the sun.
The plasma made of electrically charged protons and electrons creates a magnetic
field as they move. And this magnetic field then shapes the flow of particles.
They're stuck in a dynamic feedback loop called a dynamo,
which keeps the sun's magnetic field alive.
This magnetic field stores,
enormous amounts of energy and leaks out over the solar system.
It carries with it, a constant trickle of solar plasma,
like a light rain known as the solar wind creating a sort of space weather,
but it isn't always calm and smooth as the sun's plasma,
churns and flows around itself. Its magnetic field gets all Kings and twist it.
This creates magnetic knots that build up enormous amounts of energy.
When the magnetic knots break like a tangle of Springs, exploding outwards,
the sun that can vomit plasma and other awful things into the soda system.
These soda storms come in many times like solar flares,
a tidal wave of high energy radiation.
They race through the soda system at the speed of light,
sweeping up protons in the solar wind,
accelerating them into a high-speed solar proton storm.
Then there are carnal massive junctions,
which rip millions or billions of tons of plasma from the sun's atmosphere,
catapulting it through the solar system at speeds of up to 9 million kilometers
per hour. When these monsters hit us,
nothing happens on earth while even smaller storms can damage satellites
affects radio communication.
What will be dangerous to astronauts for people on the surface space?
Weather is harmless Earth's atmosphere protects us from the worst effects of a
soda flare by absorbing the blast of x-rays high up in the atmosphere. Well,
before it reaches the surface,
the electrified plasma from a CME is deflected by the Earth's magnetic field.
Diverting the energy storm to the and South poles were energetic.
Particles fall into the atmosphere,
causing the atmosphere to glow and creating beautiful auroras
as with any sort of weather. Most of the time, things are fine.
Sometimes there are hurricanes though,
or in the case of the sun sodas superstorms and we know that they happen
once or twice every century. If one were to happen today,
we would first detect a strong.
So the flares are sort of flash before the much more dangerous thunder.
The thunder is a CME consisting of billions,
of tons of hot magnetic plasma that crosses the 150 million kilometers between
the sun and earth in less than a day. When it arrives,
it causes a shockwave that violently compresses,
the Earth's magnetic field and transfers energy into the magnetosphere,
but it can get worse.
If the magnetic field of the CME is aligned to Earth's in just the right way,
the two magnetic fields merge as the magnetic cloud passes over earth,
it stretches the Earth's field into a long tail.
Eventually the energy stored in the tail becomes too much to contain it snaps
and explosively releases its energy towards earth.
A geomagnetic storm has begun a few hundred years ago.
Nobody would have cared.
This storm gushing over the earth is not relevant for machines made out of meat
and bones, but it's very relevant for machines made out of metal and wire.
Remember the dynamo magnetism creates electric currents earth in the
21st century is covered in millions of kilometers of wires,
transporting electricity and a complex grid of machines like transformers that
make this transfer possible.
A CMIO energy can induce currents in our power grid that can either completely
shut it down or worse.
Destroy the transformer stations that keep our grid running.
This has happened already like when the Quebec power grid failed after a strong
soda storm in 1989, but in general,
our engineers know how to deal with these storms.
And so we usually don't even notice the last time a solar hurricane washed
over earth was in 1859. The Carrington event,
the largest geomagnetic storms ever observed on earth.
Massive auroras occurred as far South as the Caribbean. In some places,
they were so bright that people got up thinking the sun was rising.
Luckily we only had one sort of modern technology, Telegraph systems.
They failed all over the world,
shopping their operators and chucking out sparks. Today.
We have a tad more technology and our luck may run out soon,
another bad. So the storm is bound to happen.
Eventually a storm as strong as the Carrington event missed earth only by a
small margin in 2012 studies projected that it would have inflicted serious
damage to electronic systems globally costing up to $2.6 trillion
to the U S alone.
The time to replace all the damaged systems was estimated at between four and 10
years. It's hard to say how bad it could have been experts disagreed.
Some assume there would just be temporary blackouts, but others worried.
It could be much worse.
We won't know for sure until a big solar hurricane hits us.
The probability of such an event is estimated to be 12% per decade.
That's about a 50 50 chance of at least one in the next 50 years.
And there is more unsettling news.
A 2019 paper found that even calm stars like our sun can create
super flares. Every few thousand years,
eruptions orders of magnitude stronger than the strongest storms we have
observed in the solar system. If such a storm hits us unprepared,
the consequences could be catastrophic.
It's hard to overstate how much we depend on electricity.
It's not just the lights at home. It means no computers, no communication,
no navigation,
a sustained power outage might lead to a breakdown of the supply chain,
water supply systems,
failing and hospital generators running dry supermarkets,
not being refilled while food rots in the fields,
the lack of power might make it extremely hard to reboot our broken power grid,
taking years or decades to restart our starving civilization.
Okay. Time to panic.
As much as daily newspapers might like for solar storms to send this back to the
stone age, they probably won't. Fortunately, even though solar storms,
aren't preventable virtually all of their nasty side effects are the
scientists observing the sun have a few hours up to a few days to see a CME
coming.
And the engineers working the systems that keep the world running are well aware
of the risks posed by soda storms,
transformers and substations can be taken offline, short,
preventative blackouts, or in other words, by unplugging stuff,
engineers can open up extra lines to dissipate the extra power and with
investment and upgrades cheap compared to those other natural disasters require
we could protect the world's electric grid against even the nastiest of storms.
But we do need to prepare while the risk is manageable.
It is real for one hour. Sunbathes us in warm and pleasant light.
One day, it might send a monster our way that we better be ready for
this video was sponsored by you.
Cuts cause dunked videos are only possible. Thanks to your direct support.
For example,
if you want to stare at our smooth and round sun for a little longer,
we've made two minimal infographic posters. One about the scale of the sun.
And what about the age of the universe?
Both should make you feel sufficiently tiny and help you appreciate your
existence a bit more, but wait, there's more.
We have a bunch of new stuff from the long requested bacteria,
phage infographic poster to a new optimistic near there's in poster that lets
you enjoy some dread in style or join us in our ant
obsession and get the new aunt Explorer notebook with beautiful infographics and
facts about ants and gold lettering on the cover.
If you'd rather update your wardrobe,
have a look at our beanies or t-shirts or you know,
all the other stuff we put a lot of love and care into developing our products
and only make stuff we want to have ourselves. If you want to support.
Cause cause ARDS getting some merges the best way to do it while receiving
something beautiful in return.
Thank you for your support and thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].